STARTED WITH OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY BEFORE WE BEGIN
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT ON
PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT THIS
HEARING. ANY WITNESS WHO DID
NOT MAKE THE REQUEST IN
ADVANCE- AND ARE OR NOT ON OUR
WITNESS LIST WILL BE LIMITED TO
NAME ORGANIZATION APPOSITE
POSITION. NO EXCEPTIONS WILL BE
MADE WE APPRECIATE YOUR CARP
COOPERATION WE HOPE AUTHORS A
STAKEHOLDERS ARE RESPECTFUL OF
THE PROCESS. WELCOME TO THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING
DUE TO CONTINUE STAY HOME ORDER
WE ARE PRACTICING FISCAL
DISTANCING HEARING HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL-
WITH SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE ALSO
REQUIRE THAT MASK THE WARNING
FISCAL DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED
BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE. IN THE
ROOM OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE DO NOT HAVE A
MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU. TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS- WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL CONTINUES
TO STAFF A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIXTIES SPACING
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT DISTANCING
PCA PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITOL.
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
WEST OF PUBLIC TO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE OF OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
ELIMINATING. LIMITING ELEVATOR
USE TO TWO PERSONS AT A TIME
NOW ACTUALLY. TO GENERAL BE
TAKEN UP IN THE ORDER LISTED ON
THE AGENDA IN THE DAILY FILE-
FOR THOSE. WHO ARE VIDEO
WITNESSES. IN THAT WE ARE-
BEING ABLE IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE. MAY HAVE
SOME WITH BILL WITNESSES USING
WHATEVER WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
AND A REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION-
AREN'T LOCATED HERE ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM.
HOUSE TO ASK HIM AND ALSO ASK
THEM QUESTIONS. WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATED SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL- THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR
TWO. SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IN THE DAILY FILE IN ON
YOUR SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE DO SO WELL- DO SO
WELL BEFORE THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR OF A LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE. YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE MUTURI LIVE
STREAM AND YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
IF YOU'RE A WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR- FOR OR
AGAINST A BILL YOU WILL REMAIN
ON A LIVE LINE. AND YOU WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL
CALLED UPON TO SPEAK. HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HEALTH. ALSO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION PORTAL. WITH POSITION
LETTER PORTAL- WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND YOU CAN FIND THE
EMAIL ON- FOR THE COMMITTEE
THERE AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY-
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE THE WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WITH WE ALL
STILL FACE- IN FAIRNESS
EVERYONE WILL NEED TO BE STRICT
ON OUR TIME LIMITS WE'LL HEAR
FROM TWO WITNESSES. FOR UP TO
THREE MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE.
AFTER THE TWO MAIN WITNESSES
FOR EACH SIDE TESTIFIED. IF
THERE ARE ANY. WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONES COMBINE THE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IF THEY REPRESENT
ONE- AND POSITION ON THE BILL.
WILL LIMIT ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ON ANY BILL TO TWENTY
MINUTES- THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT FOR
TODAY'S HEARING ANY MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE MAY REMOVE THE
BILL FROM CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. B. FOR THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES. ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB FIVE FORTY ONE ALSO BY
SENATOR BATES. ITEM NUMBER SIX
S. B. TWO TWELVE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR PAN. AND ALSO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB THREE FIFTY
THREE I SENATOR ROTH. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME THE
NEWEST MEMBEROF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. A DOCTOR JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA WELCOME. FOR THOSE OF
YOU OUT IN THE IN THE WORLD
WATCHING OR LISTENING. A DOCTOR
REGULARS TAKING PLACE- THE THAT
THE PLACE OF- ARE NOW ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA. SO ACTUALLY
APPEAR IN THE SAME SEQUENCE IN
THE IN THE ROLL CALL JUST A
DIFFERENT NAMES SO I THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US HERE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA- I'M LOOKING AROUND I
DO NOT SEE. THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY. SO I THINK WE'RE JUST
GONNA WAIT FOR A FEW MINUTES
AND WAIT FOR A SENATOR TO
APPEAR. THANK YOU. BOB.
MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT HERE MAY. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BIGELOW BURKE. CARILLO
LARA MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO WALDRON. WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HOPE HAPPY HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
A SECOND IT'S OKAY TO HAVE A
MOTION BY. MISTER MAYES A
SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR INCLUDES. ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. B. FOR THIRTY
FOUR. ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FIVE
FORTY ONE I REMEMBER SIX S. B.
TWO TWENTY SIX. AND ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB THREE FIFTY THREE. AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES. YES
MAYES I FIGURE CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
HI BURKE. CARILLO FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS. RIVAS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I WALDRON. TEN ZERO THANK YOU
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON. AND WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR A SENATOR.
YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON. SENATE
SENATOR YOU HAVE- A BILL BEFORE
US SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SIR YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- OF ME JUST OF
PROFITS MASON IS GREAT TO BE
HERE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN FIVE
MONTHS I'VE BEEN ACTUALLY
ALLOWED ON HERE FOR SO- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR
WHCH WILL GRANT. TO PUBLIC
COST BILLS IN MY DISTRICT. WITH
THE REASONABLE EXTENSION TO
ACHIEVE FINAL SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE. THE CIRCULAR VALLEY
MEDICAL CENTER. IN THE O'CONNOR
HOSPITAL EXPECTED. TO MEET A
FAST APPROACHING DEADLINE OF
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
COMPLETE. SPECIFIC SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE PROJECTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE COPA NINETY
PANDEMIC HAS HAD A SUBSTANTIAL
IMPACT ON THE ABILITY OF BOTH
FACILITIES TO STAY ON TRACK OF
MEETING THE DEADLINE. IN THE
CASE OF O'CONNOR HOSPITAL. THE
COUNTY PURCHASED THE FACILITY.
OUT OF BANKRUPTCY. FROM A
FEELING PRIVATE ENTITY ONLY TWO
YEARS AGO- IT'S BECOME CLEAR TO
COUNTY THAT THE HOSPITAL WAS
NOT ADEQUATELY MAINTAIN THERE'S
BEEN LITTLE TIME SINCE THE
PURCHASE TO ADDRESS ITS
EXISTING NON COMPLIANT.
CONDITIONS THE FACT MATTER IS
THAT THE SENATE CORE VALUE TO
CONSIDER AND O'CONNOR. OR
UNLIKELY TO COMPLETE THEIR
SEISMIC COMPLIANCE PROJECTS BY
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES- CREATED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND OF COURSE
THE RECENT ACQUISITION OF
O'CONNOR WERE TO JUST MENTION.
SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR EXTENDS
DEADLINE. FOR BOTH HOSPITALS TO
REACH FINAL SEISMIC COMPLIANCE
FROM JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. TO DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. WITHOUT THE
EXTENSION THE SENECA COUNTY
MEDICAL CENTER IN O'CONNOR
RETOOL RISK INCURRING. AT THE
EXPENSE OF STATUTORY PENALTIES
OF FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
DAY UNTIL THEY REACH FINAL SIZE
WITH COMPLIANCE WHICH COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE ABILITY FOR BOTH
FACILITIES REMAIN OPEN. THESE
FACILITIES PROVIDE COUNTY
RESIDENTS WOULD CONVENE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND
BOTH PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
ADDRESSING THE SURGE OF COVERT
NINETEEN PATIENTS ACROSS
COUNTY. THROUGHOUT THE PAST
YEAR. SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR WILL
ENSURE. THAT THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY MEDICAL CENTER AND WILL
COVER HOSPITAL CAN KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN TO CONTINUE SERVING
COUNTY RESIDENTS. WHILE
CATCHING UP ON THE PROGRESS. OF
THAT WAS LOST DUE TO PANDEMIC-
LET ME JUST SAY- IN ADDITION TO
THOSE A GENERAL REMARKS THAT-
THIS WORK- CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACT AND SO FORTH IS UNDER
WAY- THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S BEING. ASKED FOR A HALL
PASS A TO WAIT TO GET STARTED.
IT IS A QUESTION OF TRYING TO
COMPLETE THAT CRITICAL PATH
HERE TO TESTIFY. OVER THE PHONE
TODAY IS DR MUNISH. OF THE
MONEY CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
OF THE KIND OF HOSPITAL IN
DIRECTOR JEFF DRAPER. OF THE
FACILITIES AND FLEET DEPARTMENT
FOR THE COUNTY SANTA KERR.
AGAIN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO OUR
OPERATOR. THE WITNESSES ARE ON
THE LINE IN THE LINES ARE OPEN.
THEY ARE THIS IS I'LL GO FIRST
THE THIS IS JEFF BAKER AND THE
DIRECTOR OF PLEASANTLY
DEPARTMENT FOR THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA. SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY FOUR IS A COUNTY
SPONSORED BILLS SEEK TO EXTEND
THE DEADLINES TO COMPLETE
HOSPITAL SEISMIC WORK BY TWO
AND A HALF YEARS FOR THE COUNTY
HOSPITALS. AT O'CONNOR AND THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY MEDICAL
CENTER. THEY'LL COME ACROSS
BILL COMES COMPRISES OF SIX
FIVE MCLEISH SUPPORTING
STRUCTURES. DUE TO IT THE
INCREMENTAL EXPANSION OVER THE
YEARS THE ORIGINAL HOSPITAL
REFERRED TO. AS THE NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE BUILDING ALONG WITH
THE ORIGINAL CENTRAL PLANT
REFERRED TO AS A C. U. P. ARE
THE ONLY BUILDINGS ON THIS
CAMPUS THAT ARE NOT COMPLIANT
WITH CURRENT- THE STATE
REQUIREMENTS. THE RETROFIT
SCHEME FOR THIS PARTICULAR
HOSPITAL IS TO. REMOVE THE
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE BUILDING
FROM. A CRITICAL CARE FUNCTION
REQUIREMENTS MOTORCYCLE THE
CRITICAL CARE OUT OF IT AND TO
INCLUDE ANY ACCESS AND EGRESS
CORRIDORS THE RETAIN. BUILDING
AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDING
UNDER US BECAUSE YOU'RE SIX AND
GOING FORWARD. SIMILARLY THE
CENTRAL PLANT OR THE CUP WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL BE
SEISMICALLY UPGRADED IN
TROUBLE- UTILITIES WHAT TO BE
REROUTE REROUTE IT ON CAMPUS.
THE O'CONNOR PROJECT HAS
OBTAINED THE OCCUPIED BURMA.
PLEADED THE CITY THAT WE'VE GOT
THOSE TO PROCEED AS- AT THE
CENTER SAID. CONSTRUCTION
UNDERWAY WELL I WAY. THE
GOVERNOR CENTER ON THE OTHER IS
A IN- DEPTH SITUATION THE
PROJECT IS MADE OF THREE
SEISMICALLY SEPARATE
STRUCTURES. A ONE STORY
STRUCTURE TWO STORY STRUCTURE
IN A CONNECTING CORRIDOR. THAT
CONNECTS OUR INPATIENT
BUILDINGS TO THE NORTH ANDOVER
CAMPUS THE OTHER BUILDINGS ON
THE SOUTH AND THE CAMPUS. ALL
OF THESE PARTICULAR FACILITIES
OR SECTION OF THE BUILDING HAVE
TO BE UPGRADED. TO S. B. C. TO
BE COMPLIANT. AGAIN THIS THE
OFFICIAL- CONSTRUCTION WITH ALL
A BILL ONE TWENTY TWO. AND THE
DEMOLITION AS WELL UNDERWAY.
WHILE WORKING BOTH OF THE
PROJECT IS UNDERWAY THE CROWN
OF SPENDING BECAUSE I. ABOUT
OUR SCHOOL. THE SPACE. THE
NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE COVER
KIND. OF ON AN IDEA I. AM TO X.
THE WORK AREA. THE CONTRACTORS
OF ALSO BEFORE LOOK OFFICIALLY
AT THE HAVE TO COME WITH THE-
OF. AND COUNTY HEALTH ORDERS
BECAUSE SOME OF THEM. ARE URBAN
EXPO TO COPE. THESE CASE. THEIR
EMPLOYEES BUT TO WORK THROUGH
TO THE REQUIRED APPLICATION
PORTANTINO. ADDITIONALLY THE
PANDEMIC HASN'T DISRUPTED
SUPPLY LINES. AND TERMS OF
MATERIALS EQUIPMENT NEEDED TO
DO CONSTRUCTION PROJECT- GIVEN
THE DELAYS. FROM CODEPENDENT
ACCOMPANIED TO ADDRESS EXISTING
ON COMPLAIN CONDITION AND BRING
UP THE CODE THE JULY ONE
TWENTY. TWENTY TO DATE. IS NOT
A REALISTIC DATE OF COMPLETED
PROJECTS SENATE BILL- FIVE
SIXTY FOUR. THAT WOULD EXTEND
THE DEADLINE TO DECEMBER THIRTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR FOR
THESE COUNTY ON HOSPITAL SANTA
CLARA. I THINK OF THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION CERTAINLY THANK
THE SENATOR FOR HIS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. I DOUBLE
CHAIRPERSON WOULD AND ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS VANESSA THE MONEY AND I
AM THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
AT O'CONNOR HOSPITAL. SANTA
CLARA VALLEY MEDICAL CENTER IN
O'CONNOR HOSPITAL ARE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS OF THE COUNTY'S
FULLY INTEGRATED AND
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM OUR HOSPITALS
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
COMPASSIONATE AND ACCESSIBLE
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL COUNTY
RESIDENTS. THE COUNTY THREE
HOSPITALS AND ELEVEN COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS COMPRISE THE
SECOND LARGEST PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IN THE STATE
SERVING A DIVERSE POPULATION OF
OVER TWO MILLION COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND OTHERS FROM
BEYOND THE BAY AREA REGION. OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM EMPLOYS OVER TEN
THOUSAND PROFESSIONALS A
MEDICAL STAFF OF OVER TWO
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS AND HAS AN
ANNUAL OPERATING BUDGET OF TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. A
COMPREHENSIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM HAS ONE
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE LICENSED
BEDS AND LAST YEAR ALONE WE HAD
ONE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
INPATIENT DAYS AND
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
OUTPATIENT VISITS. OUR SERVICES
INCLUDE ADULT AND PEDIATRIC
TRAUMA CENTERS A REGIONAL BURN
CENTER A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
REHABILITATION CENTER AND MANY
OTHERS ARE HEALTH SYSTEM
ENSURES THAT EVERYONE IN OUR
VALLEY HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY CARE THAT'S DALY RANKS
AMONGST THE BEST STATEWIDE AND
NATIONWIDE. IN MARCH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA PURCHASED O'CONNOR
IN ST LOUIS REGIONAL HOSPITALS
TO ASSURE CONTINUED
AVAILABILITY OF ESSENTIAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AFTER THE
ACQUISITION THE EXTENT OF
SEISMIC ISSUES AT O'CONNOR'S
BUILDINGS BECAME APPARENT
ADDITIONAL UPGRADE TO WORK ON
OUR NINETEEN FIFTIES ERA
BUILDINGS. WERE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS SEISMIC ISSUES. THE
COUNTY HAS EMBARKED ON SEVERAL
PROJECTS O'CONNOR UPGRADE AND
IMPROVE EQUIPMENT FACILITIES
AND SYSTEMS. INCLUDING A NEW
FIRST IN CLASS ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM UPGRADE TO
OUR PHARMACY TO COMPLY WITH NEW
CODES. NEW IMAGING EQUIPMENT
AMONG MANY OTHER NEEDED ITEMS.
THE COUNTY HOSPITALS HAVE
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
RESPONDING TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE COUNTY
HEALTH SYSTEM HAS ADMINISTERED
ABOUT HALF OF ALL CODE
VACCINATIONS AND TESTS
PERFORMED IN OUR COUNTY. OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM IS ORGANIZING AND
STAFFING THE FAIRGROUNDS IN
LEVI'S STADIUM MASS VACCINATION
SITE. IN ADDITION TO SITES
ACROSS THE COUNTY FOCUSING ON
AREAS HARD HIT BY CO THAT TO
HELP ENSURE. EQUITY IN OUR
EFFORT. SEARCH CAPACITY
INCLUDING STAFFING ICU BEDS
WERE USED EXTENSIVELY TO SERVE
THE LARGE INFLUX OF PATIENTS
OVER THE THREE WAVES OF COVERT
HOSPITALIZATION. I COMMERCENTRE
AND EMERGED APARTMENTS DOWN
READY TO RESPOND AS IS THE CASE
WITH THE TRAGIC MASS SHOOTING
AT THE VTA FACILITY TWO WEEKS
AGO AND AGO REGARDING FESTIVAL
TWO YEARS AGO. RESPOND TO
EVENTS LIKE THESE DEMONSTRATE
THE VALUE OF OUR OUR SYSTEM
PROVIDE TO OUR COMMUNITY. IN
CLOSING AS A PANDEMIC IS SHOWN
MAINTAINING HOSPITAL OPERATIONS
AND CAPACITY THE CRITICAL ISSUE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY. SB FIVE
SIXTY FOUR WILL HELP THE COUNTY
HEALTH SYSTEM MAINTENANCE
CAPACITY AND ABILITY TO SERVE%
OUR COMMUNITY WHILE WE CONTINUE
RETROFITTING FACILITIES TO MAKE
SEISMIC REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES- PRESENT IN
THE HOUSE IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS TO MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE IN YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISTRUST WRITER. HEN LADEN
GERMANS ON THE PHONE LINE IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AT THE TIME WE DO
HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND WE'LL GO TO
WILL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
VIBER YOU GOING HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION THAT WE HEARING
WHAT ABOUT THE FIVE FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE SIR. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
QUEUING UP IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT OKAY. AND WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BIANCA MARTINEZ
PRESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I AM- SB THREE
ELEVEN. SAMSARA RUN BILL- BUT-
THANK YOU WILL REMEMBER THAT-
ANYONE ELSE FOR SB. FIVE SIXTY
FOUR. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER IN Q.
WILL GO TO NUMBER THIRTY THREE-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THE BILL'S
SPONSOR A WANT TO THANK CENTER
CORTESE ENERGIZED ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE MORE TIME
ANYONE ELSE ON SB. FIVE SIXTY
FOUR. AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE A WE HAD A MOTION BY
MISTAKE YOUR CAREER THINK A
SECOND WAVE MR BIGELOW- CENTER
EQUITIES THIRTY EXCUSE ME
CENTER CORTESE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YES FIRST OF ALL LET
ME JUST SAY AS A MATTER OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I WASN'T
BEING FACETIOUS WHEN I OPEN
TODAY. THIS IS- THE FIRST TME
A CORTESE HAS STOOD ON THIS FOR
A 2% SINCE MY FATHER WAS. A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN THIS ASSEMBLY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX SO. I MEANT
THAT- VERY SINCERELY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR. OF
MOTION IS- DO BY MISTAKE YEAR
CURRY A SECOND BY MR BIGELOW
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT HI
WHAT I. MAYES MAYES I
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW I'M SORRY ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
AYE BURKE. CARILLO. CARILLO I
FLOOR LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN IN THIS AREA AND I
RIVAS. RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I WALDRON WALDRON I. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF BILLS OUT LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER SAT ON
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
WELCOME TO THE FLOOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY TOO. BY THE WAY THANK
YOU. SENATOR HUESO. PLEASE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR S.
THANK YOU THREE ELEVEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN IT REALLY
IS A PLEASURE TO BE ANY. IT'S
REALLY A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
BACK IN THE CHAMBERS BEEN OVER
A YEAR. SO FEELS LIKE I HAVEN'T
BEEN HERE IN A VERY LONG TIME
IT REALLY- REALLY- HAPPY TO BE
HERE BUT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME 2% SB THREE ELEVEN THE
COMPASSIONATE ACCESS. TO
MEDICAL ACCESS ACTOR RYAN'S
LAW. WE WANTED A NAME THIS BILL
AFTER RYAN BARTEL LOOK
CALIFORNIA NATIVE. AND A US
COAST GUARD VETERAN WHO
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER A BRAVE
BATTLE PANCREATIC CANCER. HE'S
BEEN HIS FINAL WEEKS IN A
HOSPITAL WHERE WE HE WAS GIVEN
MORPHINE. AND FENTANYL FOR HIS
EXTREME PAIN. BUT HE'S MAINLY
SPENT HIS FINAL FINAL DAYS OF
SLEEP. WHEN HIS FAMILY TRIED TO-
VISIT HIM HE'D BE ASLEEP MOST
OF THE TIME A REALLY- ON
CONSCIENCE HIS FAMILY TRY TO
INTRODUCED MEDICAL CANNABIS WAS
TREATMENT PLAN SO HE COULD STAY
AWAKE AND VISIT WITH HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS IN THIS RICK
REMAINING DAYS THEY WERE TOLD.
IT WAS NOT ALLOWED. THEY
FINALLY FOUND A PLACE THAT
WOULD. ALLOW THE- WHO WOULD
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO GIVE HIM
MEDICAL CAN'T CANNABIS SADLY HE
ONLY HE ONLY LIVED A FEW MORE
WEEKS BUT IN HIS FINAL WEEK SHE
WAS ABLE TO HAVE A QUALITY OF
LIFE IN HIS ROOM REMAINING
DAYS. THAT HE DID NOT HAVE BEEN
THE FIRST HOSPITAL THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT NO PATIENT OR
FAMILY MUST GO THROUGH THAT
HEARTBREAK AGAIN. RYAN'S LAW
WOULD REQUIRE THAT HOSPITALS IN
CERTAIN TIMES OF HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES IN STATE. LAW
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS TO USE
MEDICAL CANNABIS FOR THE
TREATMENT. AND FOR PAIN RELIEF-
YOU RECALL WE APPROVE THIS BILL
UNANIMOUSLY IN BOTH HOUSES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR DUE TO THE FEAR
THAT THE FACILITIES MIGHT LOSE
FEDERAL CMS FUNDING. IF THEY
WERE TO COMPLY. SINCE THEN
WE'VE HAD A BREAK THROUGH. AND
A FEW MONTHS AGO WE RECEIVE
CONFIRMATION IN WRITING FROM
CMS. THAT THE MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID REGULATIONS DO NOT
ADDRESS THE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS. AND CMS STATES. THAT
IT IS NOT AWARE OF A PROVIDER
THAT HAS SPECIFICALLY LOS
FUNDING OR BEEN PENALIZED FOR
PERMITTING. THE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY AND IN OTHER UP OF
MEDICAL FACILITIES THIS IS BEEN
ALLOWED AND THEY HAVEN'T HAD
ANY SINGLE PROBLEMS FURTHERMORE
THE CMS THEY SAID IT WOULD NOT
SITE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. FOR
ALLOWING MEDICAL CANNABIS USE
UNLESS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS MADE AN ADVERSE
FINDING. CURRENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
PROHIBITED TO USE ANY FEDERAL
FUNDS TO INTERFERE WITH STATE
MEDICAL CANNABIS LAWS. AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE
IT EVERY INDICATION THAT IT
WILL NOT INTERFERE WITH STATE
CANNABIS LAWS MEDICAL OR
RECREATIONAL. THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE THE RISK FOR FEDERAL
INNOVATION AS LITTLE TO NONE.
WITH THIS CONFIRMATION FROM CMS
IN THE SIEVE SAFEGUARDS IN THIS
BILL WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES HAVE THE
NECESSARY AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL WE CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
SERVICES SEE ASIAN. AND STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WILL BE MEETING SOON WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DPH IS
REEVALUATING ITS TWENTY
NINETEEN STANDS GIVEN THIS
UPDATE NCHA HAS INDICATED THAT
IT WILL SUPPORT THE BILL IF DPH
DETERMINES THEY DO NOT NEED TO
SITE PROVIDERS FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH THIS BILL. I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR WILL GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF TWO
WITNESSES REGISTERED IN SUPPORT
SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
OPERATOR. THE WITNESSES LINES
ARE OPEN. THIS IS DOCTOR DONALD
CLINE SHOULD I GO FIRST PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIR DONALD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN HEALTH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR
DONALD CLINE. F. HERE TO SPEAK
TO AN INDIVIDUAL NOT AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF ANY OUTSIDE
AGENCY. THAT I WORK FOR THE
STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT FROM
THE PUBLIC HEALTH THIRTY FIVE
YEARS RETIRED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. SO THE FIRST TIME I WAS
ONE OF TWO PROPANE USE THAT IS
THE OWNER OF PROP SIXTY FOUR IN
THE YEAR TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH
PASSED BY 57% BURKE ABOUT WHY
WITH THE COUNTY MEDICAL.
INCLUDED THE WHITE PAPER ON
CANNABIS WHICH CALLED FOR THE
ACTIONS YOU SAW PROP SIXTY FOUR.
THIS BILL IS AN ATTRACTIVE.
PRESS TRUST OF PEOPLE ARE
BASICALLY SET UP NEW INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA AND STRUCTURE TO
ALLOW THE KINDS OF CONTROLS WE
NEED FOR BOTH PUBLIC BENEFITS
AND PROTECTIONS. HOWEVER YOU
CAN'T SET UP AN INTERNAL
INDUSTRY AND JUST SIXTY SIX
SIXTY TWO PAGES WHICH IS WHAT
THE- OPPOSITION WAS. YOU CAN
ONLY PROVIDE THE STRUCTURE AND
FRAMEWORK UPON WHICH THE STATE
CONTROL AGENCIES AND THIS
LEGISLATURE LET YOU. BUILD
POLICIES TO ALLOW OUR PEOPLE TO
ENJOY THE BENEFITS OF CANNABIS
WHILE LIMITING ITS ABUSES. THIS
ACTMANDATES PERMISSIVE USE OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS FOR SOME
PATIENCE AND SOME HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES TO ENJOY THOSE
BENEFITS. THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
POLICIES AND EXPRESSED IN THE
STATUTE. NOW SINCE THE LAST
TIME I TESTIFIED TWO YEARS AGO
ON THE PREVIOUS THOUGH- WE HAVE
MADE SOME VERY NICE FINDINGS
WITH CMS CENTERS FOR MEDICAID
AND MEDICARE SERVICES. AND I
WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION THE SERVER
IS JUST BRIEFED YOU ON WHAT
THOSE ARE. THIS BILL WILL BE
HELPFUL IF YOU WANT. BY THIS BY.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
TERMINALLY ILL AND THEIR
FAMILIES DESERVE THIS RELIEF.
AS DONE MUCH OF THE HEAVY
LIFTING FOR US. PLEASE JOIN US
SOLIDIFYING THIS PATHWAY I
HEARD AND I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. YEAH
THIS IS DOCTOR LAWRIE DIRE AND
LIKE TO TAKE THIS HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF RYAN'S
LAW. I AM A RETIRED EMERGENCY
POSITION PLAN PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS. I'M ALSO
A PUBLIC OFFICIAL SERVICE MY
FIFTH TERM ON THE RIVER
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS RECENTLY I WAS
APPOINTED TO REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
ON THE AMA'S MEDICAL CANNABIS
TASK FORCE. AS YOU'RE PROBABLY
AWARE OF MARIN COUNTY IS ONE
OF. THE WEALTHIEST COUNTIES- IN
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE THE OLDEST
LIFE EXPECTANCY OF ANY COUNTY
IN THE UNITED STATES- WERE THE
PEOPLE DIED EIGHTY FIVE. SO
MANY OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
TERMINALLY ILL- DYING FROM
CANCER- PUBLICATIONS OF
DIABETES HEART DISEASE. AND I
HAVE BEEN APPROACHED BY SEVERAL
OF MY CONSTITUENTS ASKING ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY TO USE MEDICAL
CANNABIS THAT MEN HEALTH
MEDICAL CENTER- I THINK BECAUSE
OF THE INTEREST IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE HAD THE SECOND
HIGHEST RATE OF APPROVAL OF THE
DOG USED TO MARIJUANA ACT. ON
MARCH NINTH OF THIS YEAR THE
MEN HEALTHCARE DISTRICT BOARD
APPROVED BY A FOUR ZERO VOTE.
RYAN SMOG SO I'M HERE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE MARIN
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. OUR
ACCORDING TO THE AMA CODE OF
ETHICS- PHYSICIAN PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP IS A MORAL
ACTIVITY THAT ARISES FROM THE
M. PERISCOPES TO CARE FOR
PATIENTS. LEVY AGE SUFFERING
I'M ASKING. FOR YOU TO HELP US
ALLEVIATE THE SUFFERING BY
TREATING TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS AT THE RATE HEALTH
MEDICAL CENTER BUT THE USE OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS. YES AS A
PHYSICIAN AND SCIENTIST I
BELIEVE WE ARE TO FOLLOW WITH
THE- MEDICAL RESEARCH JOBS AND
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF SCIENCES
ENGINEERING AND MEDICINE-
PUBLISHED A REPORT DAY REVIEW
OF THE FIFTEEN THOUSAND STUDIES
INVOLVING CANNABIS IN THEY
FOUND THERE'S CONCLUSIVE
EVIDENCE THAT CANNABIS IS
EFFECTIVE. IN TREATING CHRONIC
PAIN NAUSEA PARTICULARLY DUE
TO- TO- CHEMOTHERAPY WHICH
CANCER PATIENTS ARE RECEIVING
AND ALSO MUSCLE SPASM MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC PAIN
NAUSEA DUE TO THEIR CARE WITH
THERAPY. OUR PATIENTS IN A
HOSPITAL SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO APPROVE
RAIMES LAW SO WE CAN DO WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO IS TO HELP
ALLEVIATE OUR PATIENTS.
SUFFERING THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON NOW WE DO
HAVE A REGISTERED WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX OFF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION- WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR HIS STAFF AND
THE SPONSOR MISTER BARTEL FOR
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME WITH US
AMONG WORKING THROUGH THIS
ISSUE- AND FOR THEIR ADVOCACY
FOR PATIENTS. CJ IS NOT OPPOSED
TO THE USE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
OR EVEN NECESSARILY THE USE OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS AND HOSPITALS.
HOWEVER IT IS NOTED AND HIS
VETO MESSAGE OF A NEARLY
IDENTICAL BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM WROTE
THAT HEALTH FACILITIES MUST
COMPLY WITH ALL FEDERAL LAWS IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THEIR SERVICES. AND THAT IT
WOULD CREATE SIGNIFICANT
CONFLICTS BETWEEN STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW CANNOT BE TAKEN
LIGHTLY- OF GREATER CONCERN IN
ITS LETTER OF OPPOSITION TO THE
SAME BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH STATED THAT THEY
MUST SITE HOSPITALS FOR
ALLOWING THE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS. FOR THAT REASON WE DO
REMAIN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION- FOR THE BILL TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. IF CANNABIS IS
REMOVED AS A SCHEDULE ONE DRUG
POINT TILL WE RECEIVE UPDATED
GUIDANCE FROM A REGULATOR WHICH
INDICATES HOSPITALS WILL NOT BE
CITED FOR FOLLOWING STATE LAW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE IN YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTRUST WRITER. HAMLEYS
WILLIAM IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT IN OUR QUEUE OKAY
GREAT PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN
YOU'RE READY. WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
POLICE ARE PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF
EACH IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE ELEVEN THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. IT IS NUMBER
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA
LARGEST VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
CANNABIS BUSINESS IN THE STATE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
ELEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE ARMSTRONG DIRECTOR OF
INDUSTRY AFFAIRS FOR AMERICANS
FOR SAFE ACCESS WE SEND A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL I
ALSO IN THE POLICY CHAIR FOR
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COALITION WHICH HAS- ALSO
ENDORSED SYSTEMS KANSAS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS IS
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THIS IS SAN DIEGO
CITY COUNCILMEMBER FOR DISTRICT
SEVEN ROLE CAMPILLO I JUST WANT
TO SAY AND IN SUPPORT OF RYAN
LAW AND ALSO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED HERE'S A GREAT
WORKING SUBDISTRICT SEVEN.
THANK YOU- OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS ERIC
HOPMAN FROM THE GEORGE SCHOOL
OF LAW LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC
POLICY CLINIC IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LAUREN BRANDON MCKINNEY AFTER
ONCOLOGY AND HOSPICE NURSE AND
I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE ELEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ALEX TALK WELL I'M A
RECENT GRADUATE AT THE MAJORITY
SCHOOL WIRES ARE CRIMINAL AND
ALSO IN THE LEGISLATIVE AND
PUBLIC POLICY CLINIC I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. KITREY
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL INSTRUCTOR
FOR THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
RESIDENTS AND IN TRUMP SUPPORT
OF SB. THREE ELEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. I
DO HAVE A I DO HAVE A QUESTION
ACTUALLY QUIZ QUESTION FOR THE
OPPOSITION- IF OF MR AUTHORS TO
ON THE PHONE. I'M HERE
RESEARCHER GREAT THANK YOU- SO
WE DID HEAR FROM THE SENATOR-
THAT THEY HAVE SOME FEEDBACK
FROM- FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHAT IS IT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR- IT. IN A IT N.
CONTINUING WITH OPPOSITION OR
WHAT IS IT WHAT IS IT WHAT
EXACTLY IS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR. SO THE MAIN POINT OF OUR
CONCERN IS THAT- FOR THE
PREVIOUS BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. WHICH REGULATES
HOSPITALS AND LICENSES LICENSES
US- AND NOT ONLY ENFORCES LAWS
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO DOES
LICENSING AND OVERSIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IN YOUR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION THEY SAID THEY WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO CITE HOSPITALS.
SO WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IS- AN INDICATION- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
AND REVISITING OF THEIR
POSITION. THAT THEY WILL NOT
HAVE TO CITE HOSPITALS FOR
COMPLYING WITH STATE LAW. SO
THE SITE HOSPITALS BASED ON
STATE LAW IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THAT THERE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO OUR OUR DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH ACTUALLY
OVERSEAS. CANNABIS AS WELL
REGULATORY AGENCIES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CITE HOSPITALS. IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
REQUIRED ISN'T HOSPITALS ON
BEHALF OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WAS ACCORDING
TO THEIR LETTER- AND WE FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE ANY INTENTION OF
DOING THAT SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
ASKING FOR IS WHAT IS IT THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR- DO YOU WANT
TO. HELP HELP ME UNDERSTAND. WE
LIKE TO HAVE A FORMAL WE DID
SEE THE EMAIL FROM CMS- WHAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE IS A OF
A FORMAL STATEMENT THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AGREES THAT THEY WANT THAT THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE REQUIRED TO SIDE. OKAY
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL BRING IT BACK-
WE DO HAVE- JUST WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM WAS MOTION WAS FOR
MR SANTIAGO SECOND WAS WITH. A
PRIME BELIEVE WAS FOR MR
RODRIGUEZ VIRUS CORRECT. WITH A
RIGHT OR NOT. IT WAS NOT FROM
MR RODRIGUEZ. IT WAS FROM THIS
SIDE OF THE ROOM. THE SECOND
WAS. OKAY WHAT HE'S GONNA DO IT
ANYWAY BUT IT WAS FOR MISTER
TOBACCO NOW MR RODRIGUEZ THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE SENATOR. YES THANK
YOU- AND WELL CURRENTLY THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY NO STATEMENT ON
OUR BILL THAT THEY WILL SIDE IF
IT PASSES AND WE ARE WE DO HAVE
A CONFIRMATION THAT THEY WILL
NOT SITE IF. THEY IF THE BILL
PASSES SO WE'RE WORKING ON
GETTING A LETTER OF A PROVIDED
I THINK THEY'LL BE VERY HELPFUL
SO THAT'LL BE OUR OUR NEXT
COURSE OF ACTION BUT IT TO ME-
IF EVEN THE US IT IS
INCONCEIVABLE TO ME GIVEN THE
SAFEGUARDS IN THE BILL THE EXIT
STRATEGY IN CASE. WE RECEIVE
ANY KIND OF NOTICE THE BILL HAS
A SAFE HARBOR THAT ALLOWS US TO
SUSPEND THE LAW SO- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT ELSE TO WORK INTO THE
BILL TO MAKE IT- SATISFACTORY
TO EVERYBODY INVOLVED BUT WE DO
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD TO- BRING THAT
INFORMATION FOR BECAUSE I THINK
IT'LL BE VERY HELPFUL TO THE
BILL. HELPING IT TO GET A
SIGNATURE SO- IT AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION AND- THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO HELP
BRING RELIEF TO MANY FAMILIES
ARE PAYING- AND I AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN ALL SUPPORT ONCE
AGAIN GIVE IT GET ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO OUR WORK WE WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR PREWAR FULL
STAFF. IN YOUR SUPPORT THROUGH
THIS PROCESS THANK YOU. WITH
WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
HUESO THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I'M I'M
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR WITH
YOU ON THIS BILL. AS I KNOW
OTHERS IN THE ROOM ARE AS WELL-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. A MOTION
WAS MADE BY MR SANTIAGO A
SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ AND WILL
ASK MADAM SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES. MAIENSCHEIN AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
AYE BURKE. CARILLO YOUR I.
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. THIS AREA NAZARIAN AYE.
SENATOR THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES
IS THAT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THEIR STATUS THANK
THANK YOU SENATOR. NEXT UP-
SENATOR HER TADO WITH S. B. FOR
FORTY ONE. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. HELLO THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR FOUR ONE. YOU HAVE O
CREDIT FOR THE INVESTMENT ACT
SB FOUR FOUR ONE ALLOWS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO SPECIALIZE OR
TRAINED IN GERIATRICS TO ACCESS
EXISTING GRANT AND LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS OFFERED BY
THE STATE. CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION AGE SIXTY AND OLDER
IT'S EXPECTED TO GO TO GROW
THREE TIMES AS FAST AS THE REST
OF THE STATE BY TWENTY SIXTY
THIS DEMOGRAPHIC ALSO MAKES UP
OVER 70% OF ALL KOBE TELEVISA
IN THE STAT. THEREFORE IS IT
IS EVIDENT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
SHORTAGE- IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS NOW AND INTO
THE FUTURE. AND FOR ALL THESE
AND THAT HERE TODAY. IN SUPPORT
IT TO TESTIFY SELENA COPING
HORNE BACK DIRECTOR PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED LIVING ASSOCIATION
INJURED YOUR WRIST SO
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA. VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WEST THE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
WHENEVER THEY'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SELENA KOBE HORN BACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSISTED
LIVING ASSOCIATION HELLO
REPRESENTS LICENSED RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITY FOR THE ELDERLY
AND CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
FOR PRODUCT OF RELIEVER SHIFT
IN THIS AREA AND HOW IT PLEASES
SUPPORT SB FOUR FOUR ONE WHICH
WOULD ENCOURAGE MORE HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS PROFESSIONAL
LIVES IN GERIATRIC CARE BY
EXPANDING THE LIST OF QUALIFIED
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS THEY CAN
ACCESS COOL OF REPAYMENT
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE GERIATRIC
CARE PROVIDERS. AGING
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
GROWING AND THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND
DEMENTIA IS ALSO GROWING WE
NEED MORE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS NATIONWIDE
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WITH EXPERTISE
AND EXPERIENCE. IN TREATING
OLDER POPULATION. ALIGNED WITH
THE MATH PLAN FOR EIGHTY GOAL
TO READ NOT HEALTH AND WHAT THE
GUY PASSWORD ON ALL PREVENTION
AND- WE SHOULD DO A THE CANCER
MORE INDIVIDUALS TO JOIN THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. AND IT'S
STILL TO STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE ARE DRIVE VOTE ON
SB FOUR FOUR ONE WHICH WILL
BENEFIT HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ENTERING THE
FIELD. AND CALIFORNIANS NOW AND
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS. MAN COMMITTEE
CHAIR WHAT A NUMBER MY NAME IS
GEORGE RIFFLE AND I'M THE
CONTACT WHEN YOU GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION ALFA
ONE OF THE THINGS SENATORS
RICARDO FOR OFFERING AT THE
FOUR FOUR ONE AND FOR WORKING
TO ADDRESS THIS. SHORTAGE OF
GERIATRICIANS IN CALIFORNIA.
BAR ASSOCIATION ESTIMATES THAT
NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S TODAY IN CALIFORNIA
AND YET FOR FAR TOO MANY. THERE
EITHER NEVER GIVEN A DIAGNOSIS
OR TAKE YOUR THREE THINK ONE IN
OUR TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SPECIAL REPORT WE FOUND THAT
LESS THAN HALF OF INDIVIDUALS
LIVING. WITH THE DISEASE ARE
GIVEN A DIAGNOSIS. IN THE FRONT.
TO THAT TO BE A- BY THE PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM. EVER ASPECT OF
THEIR LIVES AND DATA SUGGEST
THAT MEET THE PREVENTABLE
EMERGENCY SERVICES. ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THAT THE LACK OF.
SPECIALTY PHYSICIANS WHO CAN
HELP IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING
THAT CRUCIAL DIAGNOSIS. AND A
CRUCIAL PROFESSIONAL IN THE POT
THAT THE GERIATRICIAN
PERSONALIZED THE NEEDS OF AN
OLDER ADULT POPULATION. YOU CAN
WORK WITH PATIENTS TO EVALUATE
WHETHER THERE HAVE BEEN
INDICATED. IF YOU LIKE
ALZHEIMERS OR DEMENTIA.
ACTUALLY CRITICAL FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- SO OFTEN
DEAL WITH SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
pTHIS ISSUE WITH EQUITY ENSURING
THAT EVERYONE IN OUR STATE WE
NEED TO THINK ACT WITH THE
CARE. BACKING NEED TO TIMELY
DIAGNOSIS OF DEMENTIA. THIS IS
WHY SB FOUR FOUR ONE FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
THE GERIATRICIAN. PRACTICING IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WITH
ALL INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
SOMETHING HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. ACCORDING TO CENSUS
DATA THERE ARE AS MANY AS TEN
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA WITH NO
REPORTED GERIATRICIAN. IN
MARICOPA COUNTY THERE TO ONE
MIGHT BE FOR EXAMPLE. IS NOT
WORTH THE FIGHT THE BY THE
DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS ALREADY
UNDERWAY CALIFORNIA. OVER TO BE
PUBLISHED IN THE PROTECT
PROJECTED TO DIVERSIFY AND GROW
FASTER THAN ANY OTHER AGE
GROUP. LASTLY OUR ASSOCIATION
MISSION IN THE WORLD WITHOUT
ALZHEIMER'S WE HOPE AND WE WORK
FOR A CURE. HOWEVER IF PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THEY HAVE
ALZHEIMER'S THAT OPPORTUNITY
MAY BE LOCKED TO THEM. FINALLY
DIAGNOSED WITH THAT OPPORTUNITY
THE PLAN IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
TARGETED CARE PROGRAMS FOR
THEMSELVES IN THE CARE GIVERS.
TO PARTICIPATE IN CLINICAL
TRIALS THAT WILL ULTIMATELY TO
A TREATMENT. BY TRAINING MORE
GERIATRICIAN CALIFORNIA CAN
HELP MORE PEOPLE ALONG THE PATH
OF LIVING WITH ALZHEIMER'S AND
HOPEFULLY ONE DAY TO ABSORPTION
ART THAT THEY SHOULD AND THEN
PROP THE PORT AND THAT'S BEFORE
FOR ONE. AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY WITNESSES LISTED IN
OPPOSITION SO WITHOUT WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES AND WILL
ASK. FOR A WITNESSES ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME-
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION. IF YOU WRAP
REPRESENT ONE SO YOU'RE READY
MISTER REITER. ONE AGAIN LATEST
JOB IF YOU'RE OF FOR A TO THE
BILL PLEASE PRAY ONE. ONE ZERO
FIRST OR UP. WE DO HAVE A IN
OUR QUEUE OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND ANY OTHER
CALLERS SEND. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE VERY
WELL- WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. WE
DO HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
MAYES I BELIEVE IT WILL CALL
THE SECOND FOR MISTER NAZARIAN-
CENTER HER TADO WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OUR MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WOOD HI
WHAT I MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. REGULAR AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BURKE. CARILLO RIO
AYE FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I WALDRON WALDRON I. FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT- WE WILL GO. BACK TO THE
TOP OF THE FILE- AND THEN ALSO
AT PLEASE ASK THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO COME TO THE COME TO
THE FLOOR SO WE CAN- VOTE AND-
CONCLUDE OUR MEETING. SO THAT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND AMEND
SECRETARY PLEASE KOPEN OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE- AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON ACTUALLY JUST
TO OPEN THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE. BURKE RIO. CAN
CARILLO HI FLORA FLORA I.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I WALDRON
WALDRON I. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEMS
THAT WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE BURKE I. MCCARTY
MCCARTY I FIFTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER FOR SB THREE
ELEVEN PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE
BURKE I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY I.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU AND THEN ITEM NUMBER FIVE
S. B. FOR FORTY ONE SET BY
CENTER HER TADO PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BURKE BURKE AT FIVE FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN
OPEN THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BURKE. BURKE I FIFTEEN ZERO
VERY WELL THANK YOU. A SURVEY
THAT'S IT. BUT THAT'S
EVERYTHING THAT IS IT OKAY.
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE THE CLOSE THE HEARING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THAT
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.